dr. Tom Friedman Frieden is the former
director of the CDC and former
commissioner of the New York City
Department of Health he is currently the
president and CEO of the initiative
resolved to save lives which works to
prevent epidemics dr. Frieden good
morning thanks so much for being with us
good morning I want to start I want to
start by putting this in in some
perspective you you follow the city
statistics very closely here in New York
roughly how many people are we losing
every day to the coronavirus right now
tragically there are hundreds of deaths
each day as many as four or five hundred
the numbers still are being verified
because it's so overwhelming for our
hospitals and health department this is
a tragic time but we are beginning to
see cases decrease and that's why it's
so urgent we prepare for the next phase
before the pandemic typically how many
people would the city lose in a single
day there were in New York City
approximately 150 deaths a day so there
are two or three times that just from
kovat in these terrible days that we're
living through as Tony and Gail just
reported there is a more encouraging
model that we're seeing that suggests
that the death rate may not be as dire
as we feared what do you make of that
model
I think models can be very helpful if
they help do things like allocate the
number of ventilators or prepare health
facilities for a surge or guide us in
when we may be able to more rapidly turn
on or turn off the physical distance
interventions but this idea that they're
going to guess the number of people who
die seems a little gruesome to me
fundamentally we need to do everything
we can to reduce the number of deaths to
as low a number as possible because
every one of those numbers is a life
it's face it's a family it's somebody's
relative and those numbers really bring
tears to my eyes
every night I look
New York City reports its its deaths
it's well over 4,000 already and many
more still being counted this is a
terrible terrible pandemic and it moves
incredibly quickly and that's why we
have to use every single moment during
this time that we're sheltering in place
to get ready for the next phase where we
need to box the virus in we need to box
kovat we need to do that with four key
measures testing wildly isolating
effectively finding contacts and
quarantine in the context if we do those
four things we can box the virus in and
be able to steadily gradually go back to
a new normal you say we need to loosen
the faucet gradually not open the
floodgates all at once in your view what
exactly does that mean for ordinary
people in terms of going back to
ordinary life well first off the
government and society needs to be ready
to test massively we're not testing on
anything like the scale that's needed
and it's taking many many weeks for the
White House and Washington to scale this
up I'm afraid we're even possibly months
away from having enough testing capacity
in this country and that's really
dangerous second we need to be able to
isolate people safely whether in
hospitals or nursing homes homeless
shelters we need to identify all the
places where it's spreading and reduce
that spread find contacts of every
person who's ill and make sure those
contacts are safe and don't infect
others if they themselves become ill but
for most people this means right now
shelter in place do not go out unless
it's absolutely essential if you do
please wear a face covering because that
will protect others as well as possibly
yourself but what we expect is that when
things begin getting better we might say
to people who are older who have serious
underlying conditions such as diabetes
or lung disease you're gonna have to
stay in for longer we're gonna gradually
bring people out and things are going to
look different we're not going to shake
hands we're going to use hand sanitizer
at the entrance of all buildings some
places may decide to take temperatures
with a new touch thermometer on everyone
who enters all these things are going to
be different we're not going to shake
hands for a long time but we will be
able to come out and to a new normal but
to get there we have to make our health
care system much safer all right dr. Tom
Frieden thank you so much for being with
us this morning